[Musik]
hey wir wollen philosophie zugänglicher
machen und das ganze in form eines
verbots dazu verdienen wir das buch
theorie des bösen von jörg müller ich
bin der laurin und ich kümmere mich um
die tonaufnahmen und sie nach glauben
ich bin die pia und ich bin die
sprecherin
ich bin der marcel studiert philosophie
und beraten die beiden wir würden uns
echt total über finanzielle
unterstützung freuen denn hinter der
produktion eines verbots steckt echt
wahnsinnig viel arbeit und viel zeit wir
treffen uns regelmäßig und trocken die
sache durch es macht auf jeden fall
recht viel spaß ist aber auch recht
anstrengend
vielleicht sagt ihr euch jetzt warum
eigentlich in diese reihe leute hier
investieren und die unterstützen aber es
geht dabei wirklich nicht nur uns es
geht auch um euch das thema ist
gesellschaftlich allgegenwärtig es
begegnet uns im weltgeschehen im beruf
und im privaten
habt ihr euch schon mal gefragt was das
böse überhaupt ist und warum wir böse
handeln dieses hörbuch gibt euch die
antwort
und übrigens falls euch interessiert wie
wir arbeiten also wie unser workflow ist
schaut euch hier unten auf unsere
crowdfunding seite um dort findet ihr
auch alle weiteren infos für euch
interessieren könnten
danke fürs zuschauen und viel spaß